kann ich dir noch nachdenklich diesen
karotten kuchen bestellen geht das nicht
so leute ich meine richtig schon fast
das ist eine currywurst ist ne
currywurst mit barbecue sauce herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja ich
hoffe natürlich geht es gut ich habe
gerade schon ein video gedreht und
dachte eigentlich können wir das video
noch hinten dranhängen
und zwar habe ich ziemlich viel
beachtung bekommen von instagram ceo
alexei mcdonald's gibt es currywurst und
ich dachte da stimmt das jetzt und dann
habe ich halt mal geguckt und das hilft
wirklich wieder so ein paar neue sachen
unter anderem currywurst und ihr kennt
ja meine videos wo ich irgendwie so die
neuesten fast food trends teste deswegen
machen wir heute mcdonald's currywurst
testing auch wenn ich mir wirklich
niemals privat diese currywurst wollen
würde ich weiß nicht mehr currywurst von
mcdonald's ich hab dann nämlich immer so
ein paar probleme auf so wenn ich denke
einfach dass es sich hier gerade
vielleicht überzeugt dass mich auch
deswegen würde ich sagen wir lagern ja
nicht lange fahren direkt mal los ich
glaube es gibt insgesamt vier sachen die
neu sind habe ich eben herausgesucht und
let's go arbeits auto leute und ich
bringe noch der müll und hat das ist
eigentlich richtig gut bei uns gleich
bestellen auffiel und deswegen haben wir
mal kartons aber dann nutzen wir
wenigstens diese kartons als mülleimer
und so entstehen keine plastiktüten
okay leute wir sind da ich würde jetzt
wieder 30 euro drauf wetten dass der typ
das hits wie immer dieser mitteilung
wider
ok also ich hatte was habe ich denn hier
gefunden ich hoffe die haben wir hier
jetzt überhaupt diese currywurst das ist
ja eigentlich das haupt dingen worum es
da geht dann gibt es irgendwie noch so
ein neues kuchenstück carrot cake hier
guck mal aber ich weiß nicht ob ich das
hier bestellen kann
und eine sache die auch noch neu war
thema beim mac milchshake vanille apfel
zimt so als weihnachten halten und noch
etwas neues
das gibt es hier auf jeden fall also
diese dieser macdonald hat eigentlich
immer alles da oben steht es glaube ich
wenn es das hier nicht gibt dann gibt es
nirgendwo
da kann man eigentlich drauf wetten und
du willst noch zwei cheeseburger ohne
gurke ganz wichtig mit currywurst mit
schicken ist sie dann aus
wahrscheinlich nicht
ich hoffe ich muss auch sagen ich bin
jetzt nicht so der riesen currywurst
fällen also es gibt wieder monopoly
steht stimmt 8000 likes gibt es nur 100
euro mcdonald's monopoly video ich bin
jetzt nicht so der größte currywurst
soll ich sagen
also ich hatte früher auch ich bin ja so
ein also ich bin nach alte ahlmann oder
ist man ja eine currywurst und wo wir
früher irgendwie schlecht von deswegen
bin ich kein fan riesen weiß ich auch
nicht ich habe ja ich habe schon viele
currywurst gegessen nur die von
mcdonald's fehlt noch das natürlich die
beste warst du mal was machen wir wenn
es die currywurst nicht gibt dann fahren
wir wieder raus
eigentlich muss man aber auch schon der
currywurst mit pommes dazu bestellen
oder bei currywurst pommes dann hat man
so eine mantaplatte dann besteht noch
eine kleine pommes dazu
damit garantiert
ich hätte gerne die currywurst dann noch
zwei cheeseburger und ohne gurken falls
das geht genau dann noch eine kleine
pommes der mac milchshake apfel zimt
vanille kann man hier auch diesen was
von mcaffee bestellen
diesen karotten kuchen nein das kann ich
leider nicht okay alles gut dann waren
sie einmal nach vorn am schalter
bescheid sagen also boss gibt es ist
nicht der typische verkäufer haben drive
diesen karotten kuchen jetzt leider
nicht da müsste ich für reingehen aber
ich würde sagen danke
ich rate nicht irgendwie manchmal welche
leute jetzt in diese uhrzeit wir haben
17 uhr zu mcdonald's gehen
es ist kein mac ist sehr an der autobahn
liegt oder so gehen die dann die leute
die hier wohnen dann zunächst also kann
ich hier noch nachdenklich diesen
karotten kuchen bestellen geht das nicht
kannst du hast du diese zwar irgendwie
klingt vielleicht dafür gehen die leute
jetzt kriegen wir sogar doch noch den
karotten kuchen
mal schauen alle karten eigentlich kann
man schon essen so 29 90 euro können wir
einfach dran halten entschuldigung ist
die eigentlich jetzt erst mal
aufgefallen dass alle gerettet haben
dass du das usb-kabel und ich typ
gegenangriff bei durch ein video das ist
mini usb av jedem video sagst du falsche
anschuldigung mit kabeln kenne ich mich
nicht aus ich kann mich nur mit airports
haus also leute wir sind jetzt wieder zu
hause
ich habe sogar noch diesen karotten
kuchen gekriegt mit 299 und wir sehen
uns vielleicht ich bin halt ein bisschen
referiert ich habe am ende noch gesagt
das ist sogar auf kamera können sie noch
den karotten kuchen dazu tun weil es
ihnen das hat er vorher schalter gesagt
kann ich hier noch nachts eigentlich
diesen karten buchen ist elena geht das
nicht und karotten kuchen und katie
price ein bisschen ähnlichkeit ist da
aber also wir haben jetzt curly fresse
gekriegt antworten suchen
das ist jetzt ein bisschen fell 29 90
habe ich auch schon gewundert als wenn
du blöde kuh euro kostet habe ich das
unnötig gesagt ich weiß nicht naja gut
ist halt so kann man jetzt nicht ändern
gut hier haben wir die currywurst und
wie wir das 1000 dann gibt's monopoly
das ist monatlich zieht das hier schon
mal abmahnung kann waren sofortgewinn
doch sofort gewinnen kann direkt hier
sofortgewinnen eistüte oder 0,25
softdrink aufbewahren und hierbei den
königreich haben wir natürlich auch noch
und sofort gewinnen
schon wieder eine pommes klein oder ein
mix an da bleibt mir richtig gut
so leute man richtet schon krass das ist
eine currywurst ist ne currywurst mit
barbecue soße
ich habe mich dazu entschieden das
durchzuziehen von daher mache ich jetzt
auch
aber wie gesagt ich hätte mir niemals
ruhe gönnen hier habe ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen curry pulver das sich irgendwie
gar einer richtigen currywurst aus
sondern hat mich emi gemischt oder war
es noch ruhig mal ganz kurzen test
wieso ist eigentlich ganz neues so auf
jeden fall aber das auge isst mit gesagt
bei dem nein ja also ich find ich den
geruch davon gar nicht so von currywurst
irgendwie auf die so nahe zu fühlen
sonst muss ich das video schneide krieg
na gut also es fehlt eigentlich auch
diese gabe mit der man currywurst ist ne
hab ich musste jetzt nicht verlieren
vieles wieder im popcorn brauche ich
wäre es eigentlich auch nicht ob ihr
eure augen zu und durch ich probier sein
[Musik]
also es ist jetzt kein es ist nicht
eklig oder so aber das schmeckt schon
richtig nach gummi ich habe schon
bessere korridors zur besten früher das
muss man ganz klar so sagen
irgendwie bekommt mir das nicht so gut
auch von dem lokal wie das so aussieht
als überzeugend ist nicht gleich mal so
da sehen die kommt es hier schon
deutlich länger aus wenn du dir
irgendwann mal denken würde dass du hast
du bock auf eine currywurst würdest du
dir die kaufen
nein liebe zu wurst filiale ringe und
herrn jäger natürlich so gar nicht weil
diese wurst essen dies im hauptbahnhof
gibt die sich dann dauernd dreht weiß
was ich meine
diese ganze hauptbahnhof richtige mann
noch wo ist wegen einem damen stand ja
davon morgen sah seine würstchen dreht
naja also leute also ich könnte sich
empfehlen seien mal so durch gefallen
aber natürlich fischer aber wir haben
hier noch apfel vanille zimt gedrängt
passend zu weihnachten eigentlich
probiert war noch aber wieso muss zimt
in jedes getränk reinlassen ist reif ist
weihnachten
ich möchte das filmteam getränke
für stücke drin war das gedränge ist
brutal
das ist eine 12 19 guck mal nach unten
und wolle hier eine klassische stücke
drin so also können wir es durchgefallen
das hier ist megageil wir haben
eigentlich gar nicht aber es geht ja
auch hauptsächlich um die car ist also
da muss ich eigentlich gar nicht sagen
heute es war halt mal wieder den essens
test so mache ich eigentlich auch ganz
gerne aber die hauptattraktion heute hat
mich nicht überzeugt wir sind kurz vor
eine million abonnenten wollte noch
sagen deswegen abonniert an den kanal
ganz fleißig dann würde ich mich freuen
wenn wir das vielleicht sogar dieses
jahr noch starten und wir sehen uns am
wieder gibt's neues video
[Musik]